Charity mobile as mentioned on lifesite
news and ranked by second vote.com
Charity mobile is one of only seven
prolife corporations Nationwide and the
only mobile phone company more
information at charity mobile.com the
following is a relevant radio program
and is protected under us copyright laws
this program is made possible through
the contributions of listeners like you
support Relevant Radio by clicking on
the Donate icon at w ww.
relevantradio.com
the Drew marani show get connected and
what he meant by that was you have the
power to vote against her you have the
power you have the power to campaign
against her you have the power to speak
against her he said what he meant that
he was talking about organizing Second
Amendment people and use the power of
organization UniFi get out there and try
to beat the people who disagree with you
use the political process to get done
what you want we've made really
very little if any progress since
Ferguson and that's because we're not
being honest about what happened there
and what happened in other places we
can't fix things if we're addressing the
wrong issues and not being honest about
what happened black lives matter A's
life matters and Justice matters your
life connected it's the true marani show
on Relevant
[Music]
Radio all right now 6 after the hour
good good afternoon everyone boy it's
been an interesting broadcast if you
missed anything and you want to revisit
it or if you want to share the
conversation you're about to hear with
others relevantradio.com go to my show
page Drew Mariani show page and uh my
producers will have these conversations
uploaded later you can listen to them
again you can download them you can
share them with others you can spend
more time the first hour is up they're
going on the second one up with Zach
King a former Satanist uh in just a few
moments and then of course this uh
conversation about Islam uh will be one
that I think we should all probably
revisit it should be a good one uh it's
going to be a it's going to be a hot
conversation uh we're going to be joined
by Robert Spencer who is a key figure in
the counter Jihad movement here in the
states monor Stuart swetland the
president of dony college and one of the
things I thought we could look at today
is just really trying to get some
perspective on this issue is Islam a
religion of
peace or is the true practice of it is
it about Jihad is it about subjugation
and is it possible for followers of of
Islam to separate the Faith from what
the Quran says they should do with the
sword uh and it can be very confusing
can be very complex you know I just
think back uh you know in terms of of of
History before
1979 nobody was expecting that Islam
would would really make any kind of
impact on on world history again you
know the world was in the Cold War at
the time the only thing the West was
worried about out was was communism and
the Soviet Union you know Islam wasn't
even on the radar but then the Iranian
Revolution took place in 79 and um when
that happened people were stunned the
Western support of the Sha uh you had
been dispo he had been deposed and and
executed and Al Ayatollah took his place
and uh you know Iran was suddenly you
know a foe to contend with but it didn't
end there the Iran Iraq war it broke out
and then Saddam Hussein invaded Kuwait
right Osama Bin Laden and Al-Qaeda Rose
we saw 911 what happened after that now
suddenly um the Islamic terms like burka
uh Ramadan Jihad these all became
household words in
America and now we're actually dealing
with Islam and for most of us I I think
it's foreign territory we're seeing
radical Islam for sure uh when somebody
gets in a truck and drives over people
watching fireworks uh in France on
bestile day they they kind of their
independence day we see people you know
taking guns and shooting innocent people
or cutting the throats of priests I mean
it's just uh it's it's horrific we look
at these acts of terrorism and and we
see a common denominator most them the
adherence of of Islam who've committed
these types of crimes around the world
and people are confused because we hear
wait a minute hold on True
Islam is a religion of
Peace that's what we're told right there
are many many followers of Islam who are
peaceloving
individuals but then you turn on your
news at night and what do you see you
know the TV the computer screens they're
filled with these stories of of
terrorism and you wonder how can that be
so as as a Catholic the confusion I
think becomes even greater because the
church teaches that Muslim worship the
same God that we do and there's a
dogmatic constitution on the church from
the second Vatican Council it's number
16 and you may want to read it I'll just
quote I pulled a sentence or two up
today it says in the first place
amongst these there are the Muslims who
professing to hold the faith of Abraham
along with us adore the one and merciful
god who in the last day will judge
mankind the document on relations
between the Catholic church and other
religions uh from that same Council says
this it says they value the moral life
and the worship they they value moral
life and they worship God especially
through prayer and arms giving and
fasting
but then we see what happens right you
know all on France it makes you wonder
uh how the council can say that so
what's what's what's the truth how do we
understand this that's what I want to
attempt to take a look at today with
with h two men who uh are well informed
on the issue far better than I ever will
be and it's a delight to Welcome to the
broadcast today on senior Stuart
swetland the president of Don Ley
College in Kansas City Kansas of course
the host of go ask your father heard
here on Relevant Radio serves as
executive secretary for uh the fellow
ship of Catholic Scholars and also
joining me is Robert Spencer the
director of jihad watch a project of the
David harwitz Freedom Center he's a very
prolific writer and a researcher he's
written numerous books and um many many
articles You' probably seen him online
uh about Jihad and about Islamic
terrorism and uh we're going to have a I
think a very compelling conversation
today Manor let me welcome you first
it's good to have you here today thanks
Drew it's good to be with you and thank
you for um starting with some of the
quotations from the second V Council
yeah you're welcome and and Robert great
to have you here today too thank you for
for you know joining us great to be here
thank you very much let me just begin
with like maybe opening statements from
from both of you m senior your your
thoughts on this and then Robert yours
and if you want to exchange with one
another feel free to go right ahead and
do that well the good news here Drew is
uh we're all Catholics um I'm of the
Latin right and Robert's of the Eastern
right but we're all Roman we're all
Catholics here who who believe in the
magisterium of the church so I just want
to put us on the same page
and I hope we're all and this is how we
should all approach issues as Catholics
is that we have a body of teaching that
comes from the magisterium the official
teachers of the church you quoted some
of it from the second Vatican Council
but then there's been Rich teaching
following Nostra Tate uh from Paul
blessed Paul I 6 and St John Paul II and
Pope Benedict and now Pope Francis so
I'm assuming that we all agree and and
receive and accept the teachings of the
council and the papal magisterium since
then so if we can begin with that then
we can can move on to where we might
disagree so I assume Robert does holds
that as as uh Drew and I hope you do as
well oh yes you're asking me absolutely
sure okay all right well great great so
so the answer is pretty clear that uh
Islam uh is uh something that we highly
esteem um uh is uh the church regards
with a esteem also the Muslims is how
that section wait a minute that's not
what it said it said this church regards
with esteem the Muslims it didn't say
the church regards Islam with esteem
that's not the same
thing okay I'll take that distinction
I'm not sure I I agree with your
distinction but I'll I'll take that um
the uh the way that uh usually Pope
Francis talks about it as followers of
Islam and uh I agree that so from my
perspective as a moral Theologian and a
church of social teaching I think it's
important we recognize that when it
comes to our dialogue with other
religions non-Christian religions
Catholic Christians have a duty to do so
and that dialogue should be respectful
and it should also lead with what we
agree about which is usually more than
we disagree so as uh Pope Francis says
in the posts Senate Apostolic
exhortation the joy of the Gospel our
relationship with the followers of Islam
has taken on great importance since they
now significantly present in many
traditional Christian countries where
they can freely worship and become fully
a part of society we must never forget
that they profess to hold the faith of
Abraham and together with us adore the
one merciful god who would judge
Humanity in the last day and he ends
that long section in that posts Senate
apost Apostolic exhortation uh saying
that we Christians should embrace with
affection and respect Muslim immigrants
to our countries in the same way that we
hope and ask to be received and
respected in countries of Islamic
tradition I ask and I humbly entreat
those countries to Grant Christian
freedom to worship and to practice their
faith in light of the faith which
followers of Islam and join the Western
countries so um uh he says face with
disconcerning episodes of violent
fundamentalism our respect for True
followers of Islam should lead us to
avoid hateful generalizations for
authentic Islam and the proper reading
of the Quran are opposed to every form
of violence so Robert is that a matter
of just a few bad apples just like there
are a few bad Catholics occasionally how
do you interpret that well in the first
place we need to make some distinctions
and uh it is very important to
distinguish between Muslims and Islam
just as it's important to distinguish
between Catholics and Catholicism there
are uh many Catholics poll after Poll
for example has shown that most
Catholics at least in the United States
contracept whereas the teaching of the
church is that contraception is immoral
the practice even if it's by an
overwhelming majority if those polls are
accurate uh the practice of
contraception by any individual Catholic
does not negate the teaching of the
church the teaching of the church is one
thing and the way any individual
practices it puts it into practice is
another since every individual is
subject to a variety of influences and
they come from a variety of sources and
so what is written in the religious
teachings of Any Given faith is not
necessarily a reliable indicator of what
any given individual believes now that
said the fact is that there are
teachings of Islam that do mandate
Warfare against unbelievers this does
not mean that Muslims should not be
treated with respect it does not mean
that every individual Muslim is a
terrorist or is pursuing Warfare against
unbelievers but we would be uh remiss we
would be derelict in our duty to tell
the truth and to Bear witness to the
truth were we to dissemble on this point
out of some misguided sense of Charity
it is not charitable to char and neness
are not necessarily the same thing and
sometimes it's important to enunciate
uncomfortable truths the uncomfortable
truth that I unfortunately have to
enunciate at this point is that the pope
with all respect and I don't believe
that this was an utterance that is uh uh
covered by the charism of infallibility
or anything of that kind is is simply an
error when he says that authentic Islam
and the proper reading of the Quran are
opposed to every form of violence this
is not just my opinion but the opinion
of all the schools of Islamic jurist
prudence and all the mainstream sects of
Islam all of which teach that the Quran
mandates Warfare against unbelievers and
this is not a minority view or the view
of people who have twisted and hijacked
the religion this is unfortunately
mainstream and traditional Islam that is
affirmed not only in the Quran but by
the example of Muhammad which is
normative for Islamic law and Muslim
behavior and by the uh the all the legal
Traditions within Islam that have
formulated Islamic law yeah this is
where we disagree I agree with Pope
Francis on this and um I think it's a
one thing that Benedict pointed out
there is a problem in Islam as there is
a pro problem in protestantism of not
having an authority where these disputed
texts can be adjudicated for their
authentic meaning but I give the witness
uh of the fact that Christians have
coexisted uh with uh Muslims uh for and
Christian churches and religious sites
have coexisted with Islam for for over a
millennium and it's only until recently
that Isis and Taliban have had to think
they've had to destroy those communities
and they thought they've had to destroy
their churches and their museums and
their artifacts and you know Muslim
didn't do that for for over a thousand
years uh for almost 1500 years so
obviously this new interpretation is not
athentic Islam it is new interpretation
Islam is to uh pardon me um Isis and the
Taliban are to Islam as the Westborough
Baptist Church is to Christianity well
that's unfortunately not the case
unfortunately these are not new
interpretations all of this uh makes
sense once one understands how Islamic
theology regards non-muslims the uh
Muslims conquered of course what had
been over half of Christendom and the
Christians in North Africa in Egypt in
the Middle East were uh subjugated under
the rule of Islamic law as per the
quran's the dictum that uh Muslims must
fight against the people of the book
that is Jews and Christians primarily
until they pay the gizia with willing
submission and feel themselves subdued
the gizia being a taxs and the
submission enforced by various numerous
very specific and detailed regulations
in the body of Islamic law these were
enforced but if the Christians accepted
them and lived under in this second
class status then they were allowed to
live and practice their faith and the
such the ancient Christian communities
of the Middle East they did Co they did
coexist with Muslims but not as equals
never as equals in and we made Jews
where and we made Jews live in ghettos
as Christians if you look back in the
Middle Ages that's not the one that's
not the standard one sin does not negate
another but the reality is that that was
the basis on which the Christians lived
in those societies Isis and the Taliban
have not rejected those teachings as a
matter of fact Isis is doing that to the
Christians again in Iraq and Syria after
they had lived under relatively secular
regimes with almost equal rights with
the Muslims but the but Robert those
churches that they destroyed were around
for for since before Islam existed and
no other Islamic regime ever felt they
had to destroy those things that's
correct and only the moderns this is a
modern aberration partly caused by this
is in reality the the the the Islamic
theology governing the subjugation of
the Christians negates the contract of
protection as it's called dimma if the
Christians Rebel and so when the
Christians rejected the authority of
Isis in the areas that Isis controls
then they were considered to be kufar
hary infidels at war with Islam and thus
their churches could lawfully be
destroyed and they could lawfully be
killed as per Islamic law the Ottomans
did exactly the same thing to churches
all over Orthodox churches and so we
don't hear so much about this in the
Catholic church but it happened all over
Anatolia all over Asia Minor and what is
now turkey when the Greeks and Armenians
were considered also the beginning of
the 20th century to be kufar hary
infidels at war with Islam it was all
the same theology that has never changed
since the beginning of Islam nothing new
nothing nothing hijacked or uh wrongly
derived or misunderstood or
misinterpreted by ISIS and the Taliban
unfortunately these things are very
traditional uh Robert my experience with
working with Islam as a military officer
working with turkey as an ally at NATO
working with t tunia and having exchange
officers from Tunisia working with uh
many many people who were of Muslim
belief uh serving in our military and
serving in other militaries we were
allied with uh presents a type of Islam
that is nowhere near anything that
you're describing they they are they
would have been and are uh they find uh
these groups to be not believers they
consider Isis and isil and the Taliban
to be non-believers they they aren't
what the Muslims throughout the billion
of people throughout the world you're
letting the terrorists Define Islam
which is exactly what they want us to do
and you're you're abing and abetting our
enemy by letting Bin Laden Define Islam
well unfortunately that's not the case
there is a great deal of dissatisfaction
with the groups like Isis and a great
many Muslims you will find who reject it
and they reject it for a variety of
reasons one of the primary reasons is
that uh Isis has rejected the uh the the
Islam of the Muslim Brotherhood the
Muslim Brotherhood being a group that
very much wants to establish a caliphate
and uh was not able to when it was in
power in Egypt for a year before it was
toppled and it's been a global movement
though since 1928 that has been trying
to establish a caliphate the Muslim
Brotherhood has very great influence all
around the Islamic World among Sunny
Muslims and they consider Isis to be
essentially competition and so they will
they they always will tell people that
they oppose Isis that Isis is not
Islamic that they abhor what it does but
it's not uh when you start to look into
Muslim Brotherhood theology it is
unfortunately not all that different
it's just a matter of they were able to
do what the Muslim Brotherhood wanted to
do you likewise will find that among
Saudis because the Saudi regime is very
much against Isis since Isis of course
has challenged its legitimacy and so
they too will tell you Saudis and people
in the Gulf will tell you that Isis has
nothing to do with Islam and so on the
problem is is that the Islam that
prevails in those areas is not really
all that different and the content of
Islamic law Remains the Same all right
my my guest today Robert Spencer
director of the Jihad watch uh project
of the David horor Freedom Center and M
sior Stuart swatland the president of
Donal Leake College in Kansas City
Kansas if you're just joining us we're
taking a look at this issue of of Islam
is it a religion of Peace how are we as
Catholics to look at our Islamic
brothers and sisters and uh really
understand uh so much of what we're
seeing unfold around us especially in
terms of the acts of violence and uh
understanding what the Quran teaches and
you know mon or or Robert whoever wants
to take this one I guess my big question
here and we can also take a few calls um
the Catholic church has a central
Authority you know when it comes to
Islam there is no Authority what's the
nature of theth Authority in in the
Muslim religion is there somebody who
has the final word who says no you
cannot interpret the Quran to say you
know you have to do X Y and Z it really
means this so mon maybe I'll start maybe
I'll start with you well I mean this is
what Pope Benedict pointed out in and in
in his famous speech that got a lot of
people riled up is that the need for
that kind of of thinking in Islam which
would bring reason to bear in critiquing
certain text I'll be the first to admit
as Robert can point out better than I
that there are plenty of texts in the
Quran that can be interpreted in violent
ways there's plenty of texts also that
can be interpreted in peaceful ways so
uh that authority of what verse trumps
what verse and how you apply what
section to what situation is is what's
needed I'll be the first to admit that I
think as you've heard me say before Drew
I think we should be evangelizing Islam
I think the only way we're eventually
going to deal with this kind of violence
is converting Islam we should try to
convert the whole world is what cathol
should be trying to do but I don't think
we're going to start converting them by
the kind of attitude that this is an
inherently violent religion I want to
say here's where we share like no matate
did here's what we share in belief we
can build upon that we'll be honest
about where we disagree like the status
of Jesus that he's more than a prophet
uh and then we can see where we can work
and pray together I remember John Paul
II in the in the Diplomatic efforts he
he went to to uh Co-op the Muslim Nation
to oppose the aggressive secular agenda
that one to opposed abortion as a
fundamental human right at the Cairo
conference back in the 90s so I mean we
have a lot in common in the moral realm
uh in the things of family life and
understanding with our uh Islamic as our
Muslim brothers and sisters and remember
Pope Francis and John Paul the referred
to Muslims as our brothers all right uh
Robert well nobody's saying they're not
our brothers every human being is our
brother or sister that's not an issue
the uh question though it's a very
common misconception in regard to the
stat of state state of authority in
Islam uh people think that because there
is no Pope in Islam No Central Authority
who says this is Islam and this isn't
that uh it's essentially like
protestantism and everybody reads the
Quran for himself that's actually not
the case uh there are authorities within
Islam and they wield tremendous
influence uh there is in the first place
the concept of itad itad is independent
reasoning on the Islamic texts the the
sources for Islamic law which are the
Quran and Sunnah and independent
reasoning on those texts is of course
essential if one is going to reform
Islam and reject the doctrines of
violence that it holds but independent
reasoning it Jad has been forbidden in
Islamic law ever since 855 the year 855
1,00 years ago with the death of the
last muched the the last uh scholar who
was deemed to be uh capable or and
worthy of interpreting Islamic law aked
IB hanbal with the death of of hanbal in
855 it's called the Gate of tahad was
closed this is the expression that is
used this means that independent
reasoning on the Islamic legal text and
that is the the the religious texts
There's no distinction between the
religious and the legal that is
forbidden bah Innovation is a tremendous
sin in Islam
so that if somebody wants to come to
these texts and say we should interpret
the peaceful passages as taking
precedence over the violent instead of
the violent taking precedence over the
peaceful ones which is how mainstream
Islam understands these things then they
can be rejected as committing bidah
Innovation and executed as a heretic
under the death penalty for heresy in
that is all shared by all the schools of
Islamic law there are schools of jurist
prudence there are four major ones inni
Islam the shaf malali and hanfi and
there Shiite ones and they determine how
Islamic law is interpreted they uh once
they reach consensus Muhammad is said to
have said my community will not agree on
an error so when there's consensus and
no innovation when these things have
been in place for 12 1300 years then
they're not considered negotiable
unfortunately Jihad Warfare against
unbelievers is one of those things uh
and to show you how seriously this is
taken in 1985 there was a theologian in
Sudan named Mahmud Muhammad Taha and
Taha actually did that there are two uh
two there's a division in the Quran it's
not really one section in another it's
not like the Old Testament and the New
Testament but there are certain chapters
come from Mecca from the early period of
Muhammad's career certain chapters come
from Medina the late period of
Muhammad's career the late period
contains almost all of the verses
exhorting Warfare against unbelievers
and they kill of them wherever you find
them and all that and that is considered
in standard Islamic theology to take
precedence over the peaceful vers be
valid for all time Robert I I've Got a
Hold there when we come back I'm going
to allow mon to respond as well we'll
take a few calls executed for heresy
we'll take a few calls when we come back
as well as we're just taking a look at
Islam and a proper Catholic
understanding of it my guest Robert
Spencer mon senior Stuart swatland we're
back right after this stay with us
[Music]
Charity mobile is the only prolife
mobile phone company as mentioned on
lifesite news and ranked by second
boo.com Charity mobile is one of only
seven prolife corporations Nationwide
and the only mobile phone company
Charity mobile offers the latest Samsung
and Apple smartphones and they send 5%
of your monthly plan price to the
prolife charity of your choice with
Charity mobile there are no contracts no
termination fees and no risk with a
30-day trial credit check required call
877-4742 or go to charity mobile.com
today mention relevant radio and get a
free 4G LTE smartphone plus free
activation and free shipping life is
calling take it with you call
877-4742 877- 474 3662 or go to charity
mobile.com today that's Charity mobile
[Music]
father Simon Says on Relevant Radio this
incredibly aggressive push to Define
lots of interesting relationship as
marriage you know you got issues I'm not
going to yell at you and you think what
you think and and I'm going to respect
you and your conscience I might disagree
with you though well you can't disagree
with me that's hate speech what do you
mean it's hate speech I don't hate you I
just bought a cup of coffee what do you
mean I don't ha you I don't agree with
you well to not agree with me is to hate
me why are you so worked up about this
you know why they so worked up about it
because they know it's not true they
think it's true but they know it's not
true father Simon says we reverence the
image of God in every person but we
speak the truth in love it's wrong to
speak the truth without love it's wrong
to Love Without speaking the truth we
speak the truth in love father Simon
Says 11 Eastern 10 Central on Relevant
Radio Hello Father James kabiki of the
Pope's worldwide prayer Network here on
the Feast of a deacon martyr of the
early Church St Lawrence he was the
Roman Deacon who was in charge of the
church's money making sure that the poor
the widows and the Orphans of the
community were cared for when he
wouldn't give that money to the Roman
Governor he was sentenced to the slow
and agonizing death of being roasted
alive a few years ago on the
1750th anniversary of his martyrdom Pope
Benedict visited his tomb in the
Basilica that is dedicated to him and he
said the
following history confirms to us how
glorious is the name of this saint by
whose tomb we have gathered his concern
for the poor the generous service that
he rendered to the Church of Rome in the
context of assistance and charity his
Fidelity to the pope which he took to
the point of Desiring to follow him in
the Supreme trial of martyrdom and the
heroic witness of pouring out his blood
which he suffered only a few days later
are facts well known to all St Leo the
great in a beautiful homy thus comments
on the atrocious martyrdom of this
illustrious hero quote the Flames could
not overcome Christ's love and the fire
that burned outside was less Keen than
that which blazed within Eddie adds the
Lord desired to spread abroad his glory
throughout the world so that from the
East to the West the dazzling brightness
of his deacon's light does shine and
Rome is become as famous through
Lawrence as Jerusalem was ennobled by
Steven for more prayer resources go to
relevantradio.com
keyword
prey what is the world's most dangerous
ideology in the first part of the 20th
century the answer was fascism first
manifest in Italy in the 1920s and then
in Nazi Germany and then Imperial Japan
it took a World War and 50 million dead
to stamp it out in the second half of
the 20th century the answer was
communism between the Soviet Union Mouse
China and their Cent States at least 100
million people were killed in its wake
today the answer is islamism a radical
and often violent form of Islam like
fascism and communism islamism is
totalitarian in nature the state
controls everything also like fascism
and communism islamism is inherently
expansionist it always seeks to get
bigger cross borders and bring as many
peoples as possible under its control
and like fascism and communism many of
islamism adherence are prepared to kill
to achieve its aims those aims are
antithetical to everything Western and
other other free sociey stand for the
truth unfiltered it's the Drew marani
show on Relevant
Radio all right 25 minutes before the
top of the hour welcome everyone taking
a look at Islam can you separate the
sword from the faith is it a religion of
peace or is it a religion of violence I
remember hearing uh Michael Savage you
might remember this too he came under a
lot of heat I think it was a couple
years ago he called the Quran a book of
hate so the uh this Council on American
Islamic relations U which is known as
care they were calling for a big boycott
of him because they said what he said
was hateful and he had brought up some
some quotes uh and quotes that you might
want to consider um and I'll share one
or two I mean this is out of the Quran
so how do we interpret these violent
quotes versus the call to peace and love
and where do we stand as as Catholics on
this I just share one or two quotes
garments of fire shall be cut there
shall be poured over their head boiling
water where whereby what ever is in
their bowels and skin shall be dissolved
they shall be punished with hooks hooked
iron rods another quote says the Infidel
should not think that they can get away
from us prepare against them whatever
arms and weaponry you can muster so you
may terrorize them they are your enemy
and Allah's enemy and the the final one
too is uh let me just another one here
um oh gosh there's so many of them um
this one fight those who do not believe
in Allah nor in the latter day nor nor
do they prohibit what Allah and his
Apostles have prohibited nor follow the
religion of Truth out of those who have
been given the book until they pay the
tax and acknowledgement of superiority
and they are in a state of subjugation
so is this a religion of subjugation is
it a a religion of violence those are a
few key verses there's others that that
highlight peaceful means my guest today
Robert Spencer he is a man who has been
involved uh in you basically uh what
I've been calling I guess the the
counter Jihad movement in the country
he's uh debating today or discussing
with mon Senor Stuart swetland president
of Don Lake College in Kansas City and
just taking a look at at that principle
there uh Robert Spencer is also the
director of jihad watch it's a project
for the David Horwitz Freedom Center and
and Robert I'm gonna let you before I go
right back to monor I went him to
address your last comments but you got
clipped in the end your final thought on
what happened to the man who was
promoting those verses saying that Islam
was a religion of Peace yeah very
briefly the classic schools of Islamic
thought the uh schools of jurist
prudence that Prevail among uh Sunni and
Shiite Muslims all teach that Warfare
against unbelievers is the last stage of
the quranic development and the violence
takes precedence over the peaceful
passages Mahmud Muhammad Taha was a
theologian in Sudan who taught that
there should be reform and that the
peaceful passages passages should be
understood as taking precedence over the
violent ones and he was executed as a
heretic by the Sudanese government in
1985 all right mon I want you to respond
to that when say you know the scriptures
tell us by your fruits you shall know
them and the fruits of over a billion
adherence of Islam is not what Robert
describes there wouldn't be Sufism if
what he described was the dominant they
would have been wiped out and now Sufism
is a minority inside of Islam but it is
a legitimate school which many practi
practitioners of Islam follow and you
have all I mean I hope everybody has
close friends who are Muslims here in
the United States if you don't I I think
you're living an isolated life that is
problem itic uh I have people who work
for me I've been in the military with
people who are Muslim I've served uh and
been in in with Muslim countries working
as as allies in our fight against
communism I've had exchange to uh uh uh
officers from Muslim countries serve
with me on ship I've trusted my life to
them uh you know this is not what Robert
describes is not what Muslims are and uh
to ascribe the religion as the that Isis
and the Taliban are the correct
interpreters of the religion I think is
to play right into the arms of those who
want to make this a war a clash of
cultures a class of civilizations and a
religious War it's not there's the West
Bal Baptist Church there's a um white
supremacist group that believe
themselves to be Christian about
people Robert let him finish Robert let
Robert Robert let Manor finish if you
could yeah but if if if our critics were
going to Define Us by these these people
who don't teach the gospel or anything
close to the gospel or anything close to
what the vast vast vast vast majority of
Christians understand the gospel to be
there is the census fidelia there's got
to be a similar thing in Islam uh the
the the the the vast majority of the
faithful practitioners of Islam are not
the way that Robert describes them do I
think it's very dangerous when uh we
have theocracy of course I do but we
have our history with that too as Pope
Francis recently pointed out
so uh uh again I think if we look at the
second Vatican Council we look at John
St John Paul II we look at what uh
Francis is teaching in the joy of the
Gospel he's calling for something
different like for example to accept
Muslims as immigrants which is a very
important practical thing we Christians
should embrace with affection and
respect Muslim immigrants to our
countries in the same way that we hope
and ask to be received and respected in
countries of Islamic tradition so I mean
we've got to take these teachings
seriously or we just become dissenters
from the faith like uh the people that
we rail against who are not upholding
the church's teaching on abortion all
right gentlemen let me go to the phones
CU we could debate together for a long
time here George is listening in
Minnesota George welcome to the program
hi there thank you for having me on the
show you're welcome um I just wanted to
uh add a little comment here i' I've
heard monor talk about Islam on several
occasions uh you know about the
relationship and how he's had his
experience with the military
and how this you know we don't want to
play into the idea that uh what certain
people do or that the uh uh islamists
are doing that it's a blanket statement
against all the other Muslims but what I
would like to say I'm I'm a Middle
Eastern Christian I'm Lebanese and uh we
understand very very very very clearly
what we're dealing with when we deal
with relations with Muslims uh my in-law
side of the family lost over 70 members
in the 1915 wow um uh genocide that took
place uh my wife is Syriac Orthodox and
as you mentioned those were a lot of
Orthodox Churches at the time that were
massacred but I I would like all the
listeners to pay very very close
attention to the guest speaker who
understands what it is to deal with the
Middle Eastern theology or the Islamic
theology uh an experience that you may
have monor with different people in the
military really doesn't bear much weight
compared to the Theology of these people
and what they are teaching and the other
thing that I would like the listeners to
be very careful to understand is that
the this this is not a new situation
this is not something that's just recent
in history the guest speaker is very
very very correct that this is not new
this has continued on for centuries and
it is in nowhere uh ready to change and
the other thing that I was very happy to
hear the speaker mention was about ishad
and for those of you who didn't hear it
please go back and listen to it again on
the archives uh ishad is extremely
important to understand why you have
these teachings of Islam the way they
are um I'm very happy to hear a guest
speaker finally mention that I'm very
happy for a guest speaker to also
mention that living the cohabitations
between Christ and Muslims which
anywhere in the Middle East the Lebanese
are prime example of how that can happen
but we do it still in fear and we have
always done it in fear and we have never
never been treated as equals well George
Community George I'm glad you called
thank you for the inight I'm gonna let
mon respond and then Robert why don't
you respond on H I was trying to make it
personal and I'm not saying that my
personal experience you know that would
be you know the mistake of being an
anotal but was trying to point out that
most people have an experience of living
around and with people that practice
Islam and they're nothing like what
Robert and I my my expertise on this I
said I'm my expertise is in the Church
of social teaching but we've got lots of
people in the church who make this their
FOC Focus like Archbishop Fitzgerald um
who's you know the Catholic Church's top
expert on Islam and what he describes in
his writings and his teaching uh is
nothing near what Robert's saying
neither is uh um
Patrick Ryan Father Patrick Ryan of
forom who's an expert on these go on the
am
get you have go ahead yeah go ahead
Robert thank you um because all these
things are piling up and I'm not getting
any chance to say anything in the first
place the last one is an argument from
Authority which is the weakest of all
arguments I'd be very happy to debate
Fitzgerald or Ryan or anybody else on
the facts on the content of the Quran on
the content of Muhammad's teaching and
so on Robert that was in response to his
his about you know I'm using examples
from my military backgr that's all I was
doing there Su go a little while ago you
mentioned the Sufi it is a mistake to
think that Sufi Islam rejects violent
Jihad it does not uh Al gazali the
founding figure of Sufism was very
strong in exhorting sufis to wage Jihad
Warfare against Jews and Christians and
subjugate them and make them pay the tax
uh as a matter of fact the sufis have
been the leaders in Chia of the Jihad
against the Russians since the beginning
of the 19th century until a whole lot of
wahhabis came in in the late 20th
century uh also the uh founder of the
Muslim Brotherhood Hassan Alana was very
strongly influenced by Sufism there
nothing in Sufism that rejects violent
Jihad or is incompatible with
it all right I'm gonna hold it at that
point Jake do I need to take a break or
can we continue I have to take a short
break here I'm getting queued when we
come back we'll take more calls my guest
Robert Spencer mon senior Stuart
swetland we're taking a look at what is
a very complex and quite com you know
you know I guess uh um what what's the
word I'm looking for here controversial
uh issue and we're dealing with Islam
how do you interpret it um and what is
our Christian response to it how do we
bring about the evangelization of our
brothers and sisters from Islam we'll
talk more we'll take a few more of your
calls on the other side as well it's
about 15 minutes before the top of the
hour stay with us your life connected
the Drew marani show on Relevant Radio
backed by your prayers and your
generosity this is listener reported
Relevant Radio I've gotten hooked on it
and so have a lot of my family members
we listen all the time relevant radio
has just absolutely been a
life-changing experience for me it's
built my faith and it's reinforced me in
my faith and it's kind of like a home
for me to come to from uh dealing with
the outside world listener supported
Relevant Radio if St Paul was alive
today he'd be sitting with you at the
microphone father Rocky says that a lot
our executive director he often reminds
everybody here of the great mission that
we have I mean it's it's a noble Mission
many Bishops are behind us Relevant
Radio reaches football stadiums full of
people every single day over and over
again our need is ongoing please call
now with your tax deductible
donation 1877
29123 or donate online at relevant
radio.com father Larry what is that key
then to that kind of Friendship with God
once we get over the tiptoeing with
trepidation around him we need to spend
time with him every day you know how do
you fall in love with anybody you spend
time with them Mass on Sunday is not
enough time you know if you give your 45
minutes to an hour depending who the
priest is every week how do you ever
expect to fall in love with God you know
what are you going to do you get married
to someone and say listen honey I'll
spend 45 minutes to an hour with you
once a week I can't wait till it's over
get in and get out the least amount of
time with you I can spend the better off
I'll be and then every once in a while
call you on the phone and just check in
on you but very briefly cuz I have
things to do nobody would marry you and
yet that's what we do with almighty God
what we have done is we've made a
relationship into just a ritual and we
look for the minimum time and you'll
never never fall in love with God if
that's all you give him as once a week
and every once in a while you need
quality time every day talk radio for
Catholic life Relevant Radio pro-life
Across America is nonprofit and
nonpolitical dedic at to changing hearts
and saving babies lives bringing
positive and persuasive messages
offering information and Alternatives
including adoption and assistance to
those in need your life connected the
Drew marani show on Relevant Radio get
[Music]
connected all right now 12 before the
top of the hour welcome back everyone
it's good to be with you today we are
having a spirited conversation a debate
about Islam you know too often the
debate around Islamic violence centers
around Doctrine around around the Quran
and and other scriptures uh you know how
do we interpret this you know forgotten
in this debate is that Islamic
scriptures um uh you know are a driving
force uh in terms of what Islam teaches
uh yet we hear often that Islam is a
religion of peace and there are a lot of
peaceloving followers of Islam I want to
make that very clear the Holy Father
came out recently and he said his quote
Islam uh is not terrorism you know he he
says I I think it's it's not right to
identify Islam with terrorism uh it's
not right and it's not true that was a
quote from Pope Francis so I'm just I
invited today if you're just tuning Us
in maybe getting out of work or flipping
on the radio uh two experts on the the
issue Robert Spencer is a director of
jihad watch a project the Horwitz
Freedom Center and uh he's a prolific
writer and he has been uh really
addressing this issue for years mon
senior steart swetland the president of
Donnelly College in Kansas City Kansas
also the host of go ask your father and
Gentlemen let's get back to the
conversation towards the end of our
conversation I want to give you each
final thoughts on the air as we wrap it
up but I'm going to go back to the phon
a lot of people have been waiting let's
go to Rockford Illinois first and Pete
uh thank you for your patience you're on
the air well thank you um it sounds like
a debate to me and Mr Spencer is winning
at for square but in any event I'd like
uh I guess monor swatland to defend the
Vatican 2 what I consider to be a
blatant heresy of Vatican 2 that Muslims
along with Christians worship the one
God Mankind's judge on the last day is a
matter of paraphrasing it Jesus Christ
the Bible tells us will be Mankind's
judge on the last day Islams do not
recognize nor do they worship the Lord
Jesus Christ so how can Muslims worship
the one God Mankind's judge quote on the
last day from the heretical Vatican 2
Council thank you very much yeah well
obviously I'm a Catholic so I don't
believe Vatican 2 is heretical and uh if
you are a Catholic and full communion
with the church you don't believe that
but uh second of all Jews uh worship the
one true God and they do not believe
Jesus was God uh so and the scriptures
are clear that they do so uh any any
group that's authentically trying to
worship the one God um and of course um
Islam is is worshiping the one God uh
and so um I I find it hard to uh to Def
to defend something when you start with
saying that a major Council of the
church is heretical that puts you
outside of communion with the church so
yeah all right Peter thank you for the
call we'll move along I'll go to take
another call Minnesota is up Anonymous
you're on the air with Robert Spencer
and monsenor swen welcome hey good
afternoon thanks for taking my call
you're welcome it seems to me I heard
what you said earlier what's in the
Quran uh um and it sounds to me like
what's in there is inciting violence
against Christians Jews the infidels I
mean it's plainly in there that can't be
disputed so the question is there's two
types of Muslims there's the Muslim that
follows the letter of the book and
carries it out and then there's the
peaceloving Muslims the mo sior was
talking about that are peaceloving
people but they're not following the
letter okay well yeah well I would
disagree with that because the way that
they they would describe it is that
Jihad is an interior spiritual battle
much like our search for Holiness should
be and they would point to passages like
Ephesians that talks about putting on
the armor of God uh that Christians
don't interpret that to that means we
have to actually go fight the other the
other side uh we may have to defend
ourselves that's another story and you
could look at uh sections like uh you
know uh uh that say in the Quran for
every soul there's a guardian watching
over it therefore bear with the
unbelievers and let them be a while so I
mean there's plenty of passages like
that as well uh so you know you're
following the letter it depends which
letter you're following which I I agree
with Robert is one of the problems in
Islam but the vast vast vast vast vast
majority of Muslims now and in history
have interpreted Jihad as an interior
struggle to become what we would call
become holy they use different language
for it but it's the same it's a similar
process it's following the dictates of
submitting yourself to God and God's
will being a person of prayer and
fasting and arms giving and following
the dictates of Islam so I mean that's
how it's been interpreted that's again
and to I think to broadly uh paint a
brush to not interpret it that way uh is
to fall into the Trap of allowing the
radicals to Define uh uh the religion
and we would not want that to be done to
Christianity all right Robert why don't
you respond
well this is not really letting the
radicals Define the religion the
mainstream and authoritative sources
within Islam the Mad hadb the schools of
jurist prudence all teach Warfare
against unbelievers as being the final
stage of the konic development which
started with tolerance and includes the
tolerance ver senior quoted and ends
with offensive Jihad to establish the
hegemony of Islam these things are not
uh the Twisted hijacked version of the
al-Qaeda or Taliban groups or Isis this
is mainstream Islam since the 9th
century
uh taught by all the schools of Islamic
law and all the uh the sects within
Islam uh the the idea that uh every any
individual Muslim may not be holding to
that is of course true as I explained
before the fact is that not all
Catholics follow all Catholic teaching
not all Muslims follow all Islamic
teaching and for that we can be glad but
we would be fool hearty not to recognize
that the teaching exists or to
extrapolate from any particular
individual who is is a Muslim and a
great guy to the notion that Islam does
not actually teach these things the
jihadis are able to and do make recruits
among peaceful Muslims by pointing to
the Quran and to the teachings of
Muhammad and this has been the case
throughout history that Jihad has been
justified by these teachings they are
not Robert just so I'm clear you think
Bill a billion uh Muslims are just bad
Muslims that the real Muslims are Bin
Laden and his type no not I never said
that the fact well that's what I'm sorry
that's what it sounds like to me well if
I can explain most Muslims actually
don't wage violent Jihad but the
question is do they approve of it and we
see surveys look at the Pew Research
Center surveys and you find incredibly
High percentages and that's only the
people who admit it to pollsters uh like
Bin Laden like suicide bombing approve
of the death penalty for apostasy and so
on and this is all across the Islamic
World these figures are readily
available and also you know it's it's
it's a difficult thing to take up arms
and to risk one's life not many people
want to do that in any context no matter
what the religious exhortation to it may
be uh the there are also many other
jihads as you've noted the spiritual
struggle actually is no spiritual
struggle in the Quran the quran's verses
about Jihad are all about Warfare
there's actually a chapter of the Quran
entitled Alan The Spoils of War chapter
eight which dictates that Muslims have
to give a fifth of the booty a fifth of
The Spoils of War from their jihads to
Muhammad which has been intered later
through the ISL Old Testament the tithe
comes from
war war there no Spoils of War in a
spiritual struggle so obviously these
things are about Warfare the Old
Testament is irrelevant unless you see a
lot of armed groups of Jews or
Christians pointing to the Old Testament
to justify violence which you do not
whereas you do see armed groups of
Muslims in every continent in the world
pointing to the Quran to justify
violence I agree that we have a problem
with a minority a small minority of
people people who are perverting a great
religion for their own purposes to uh
IDE make an ideology out of something
that should not be but I think it's very
dangerous and I don't think it's in
consistent with Catholic teaching to
broadly paint the brush of Islam I'm
what you're saying Robert is that people
like St John Paul II and Benedict and
Francis and Paul I 6 and the all the
fathers of the second V Council just
didn't know what they were talking about
and I find that hard to
believe let me let me do gentlemen
gentlemen I have three minutes remaining
here I I want to give you each a minute
and a half just to conclude Robert I'll
let you go first once you make your case
your final statement and Ms let you do
the same thing there's no doubt that I
represent a Min minority view in the
church I'm not really worried about that
because I know that what I'm saying is
true and that the truth is obvious and
will out ultimately and I know that
there are uh popes and Bishops and all
sorts of people uh who say that I'm
wrong and I think that uh within 50 or
100 years everyone in the church will
see that I was right and I will have
been Vindicated uh the fact is though
that the the the if if a view is a
minority view it doesn't necessarily
mean that it's false anybody can read
the Quran I invite all the listeners to
do so read the Quran carefully for
yourself especially chapters 1-5 and 8
and nine which all are contain the
substance of Islam's view of
Christianity and Islam's teaching on
Jihad and you'll see that what I'm
saying is absolutely true Robert I want
to thank you for being here and being
part of the conversation and monor I'll
give you final thoughts as well
well I would say to read the whole Quran
and and that you'll see that it's more
balanced and and that I know you have
Robert I'm not saying you haven't but
you said to read a few chapters if you
really want to get into this people
don't really want to read the whole
thing but absolutely people should read
the whole thing and then read my guy to
the Quran man you got about a minute
left so I want to give you final
thoughts here yeah I went back to my old
copy which is falling apart from my days
at Oxford when I seriously thought about
Islam as a part of a a potential
religion to to enter and I just I just
find it uh
uh really hard to believe to talk to a
fellow Catholic who wants to be so
dismissive of the received papal
teaching on this I I find this attitude
unfortunate it's not just an argument
from Authority we believe our teachers
in the magisterium teach with a greater
than human wisdom that comes from the
Holy Spirit and they call us to dialogue
to get to know to emphasize what we
share and there's a great deal we share
much more than with with some of our
secular brothers and sisters we share
with those of Islams uh uh and of Muslim
uh Muslim peoples
uh second we have to be honest about
where we disagree and Robert and I are
actually very close on on a lot of that
but we the third step we have to see
where we can work and pray together uh
if not we're going to be at each other's
throats which is no way for the world to
live in peace and the weapons we we have
today is too dangerous for us to be on
the brink of War all the time uh W with
uh other people based on something that
should actually build uh us closer to
one another well my senior thank you
Robert thank you both for Spirit of
debate if you just tuned in you missed
part of it relevant radio.com keyword
the Drew marani show go to the archives
you can download that conversation you
can share it with friends you could
stream it and listen to it again it's
well worth the listen I'm Drew Mariani
until our pass again cross remember God
loves you and so do I have a good
night
e e